on social media you um post a lot of
behind the scenes content so if it's
okay we have a game here we would love
to stay with you yes i would love to all
right it's the final five bridgerton
edition
[Applause]
all right we're gonna ask you some juicy
behind the scenes bridgerton questions
and if you can spill the beans we would
love it
okay number one which cast member is
most likely to break in a scene
jonathan bailey
oh really i didn't have to think about
that he's a terrible giggler and he
plays this really brooding like terrible
rake and then he's like a little girl
when he giggles so 100 him 100 okay i
love him very handy yeah all right
ladies responsible for all the gossip
around town but who's the most gossipy
cast member i'm just going to nominate
myself because i would be the one like
reading demoir and like
did you know this and this and i love
like but i think like not all gossip is
bad people perceive it as a terrible
thing but like you know when like
celebrities get together a bit you know
been apart for a long time and get back
together and then it's like joyful yeah
that's awesome but that's like harmless
joyful gossip
i like the spin all right yes i do just
make myself look good yeah i believe we
call it pop culture thank you that's
what it is
has a group chat to stay in touch who's
most likely to ghost the chat oh
you know i think claudia jesse plays
eloise
because she does not like a group chat
she's a one-on-one
girl but she's not like attached to her
phone like i'm always like but yeah
probably claudia she's like i'm not into
group chatting but she's like i'll talk
to you one-on-one
all right well which new character are
you most excited about for everyone for
all of us to meet on season two there's
a lot i mean of course the sharma
sisters they're just simone ashley and
teresa chandra and who play kate and
edwina are just gorgeous and wonderful
and they're big i saw someone doing this
in the audience yeah look how excited
they are even the moment that i got cast
in the show kate is such a big character
for the book fans she's like this real
strong woman it's very pride and
prejudice with her and anthony she just
doesn't take any of his rubbish you know
okay our favorite and least favorite
piece of wardrobe to wear oh gosh
my favorite oh my gosh i have this pink
dress this season and it's like
something off a runway it's like mimo
looking it's like fully beaded it
weighed a ton there was one thing where
i had to run upstairs and they're like
can you go quicker i was like i
physically no
i was like i was like oh then i have oh
are they gonna kill me for saying this
penelope's nightgown her um her like
dressing gown that she wears yeah it's
just not the one every day i walk into
i'm like not this great but also it's
part of pilates that she's meant to be
overdone and it's too much and yeah well
every choice that has been made along
the way and every choice that you
specifically have made has just won us
all over thank you so much so excited oh
my god celebrating you
nicholas hoffman season two
of bridgerton is available to stream
march 25th on netflix
[Music]